welcome to Trafalgar Square or at least
2,000 people have turned up to our
Scotland to please vote now on thursday
i think that one of the wonderful things
about Britishness is precise in fact
that it is slightly embarrassed national
identity people don't like to stand up
and say Britain's great and in fact what
we're saying probably isn't Britain to
get retain Britain's okay which is very
British thing to do we don't get a vote
so where's this year and if Alex
Salmond's in charge becomes I think
everything will go to thought we've
achieved so much together this this city
is built on an angle is Scottish
cooperation and I think that's one of
the most inspiring and positive stories
in history I was born there and I deeply
resent the fact i'm not allowed to birds
and these are an amazing feeling and
fuzzier from people across the united
kingdom who simply want to ensure that
this family of Nations stays together no
I can't imagine England or Great Britain
without you Scotland's choice on
Thursday not mine it helps us out before
we can do it all together again hello
learn to swim the political utopia
everyone's
remember what happened that the real
world wants to be seen in the next
morning if you care about something you
should stand up and say that you care
otherwise we're just running and hiding
I just tell everybody in scottville that
we're all [ __ ] fed up with westest
yes there are improvements that we can
make but my goal should we stick
together he's just selfish
fellow for his own Korea for his own
name boys and forums and we open a
problem this is so pointless don't like
creating borders but this picture any
sense at all I'm not going to lie we
don't want you to leave
don't stay together let's dig in